Hur ställer man in huvudet och hur ska man jobba för att kunna hantera det utan att bryta ihop på bästa sätt?
Jag tänker spontant så, så 15-20 år så kommer det att bryta ihop.
Okej, fair enough.
Ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löst det, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Aftonbladet sen.
Jag ska hitta på ett namn henne på podden.
Det är den bästa idéen vi har.
Exakt, exakt.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt, det kör vi på.
Det får det bli, klart, då går vi vidare.
Då välkomnar vi till podden Björn Rudman.
Tackar, tackar.
Och vi har ju redan lite kommit igång här och börjat prata känner jag.
Alltid är det så, man börjar köta.
Det är innan man trycker på räckknappen.
Och du jobbar som terapeut?
Ja, terapeut inom stressröterad psykisk ohälsa.
Och precis innan vi slog på så pratade vi om hur många människor som mår inte perfekt.
Och det var ett gäng, för vi funderar på vem vi ska rikta detta mot.
Du sa lite siffror, kan du inte bara dra de siffrorna lite fort?
Ja, statistiska centralbyrån ställer ju frågan har du besvär med ängsla, oro och ångest?
Och om vi börjar ner från åldrarna 16-24, där svarar 70% av kvinnorna att de har besvär.
Och sedan så går det så vidare ett hack, 16-24, 25-34 och så vidare då.
Någonstans mellan 50 och 60% har besvär med de här sakerna.
Är det någon gång under livet?
Eller är det att man...
Det är nu.
Nu nu?
Ja.
Ja, det är ju rätt...
Och det där är siffror.
Kollar man tillbaks i tid så pratar vi ju...
Vi pratar ju, jag har tagit siffrorna från 2019 och framåt.
Ja.
Och då är sista svaret, SCB får 2022.
När var det?
Putin gick in nu, kan jag gärna.
Ja, exakt, exakt.
Det har ju hänt på det.
Det är inte ens med där.
Det är inte med med räntor, det är inte med med sådär.
Så nästa kommer vara ännu värre då.
Det är så här det ser ut idag liksom.
Oavsett var man är, det är dåre som direktör.
Alla har problem med detta mer än en myndighet.
Men är det så, nu dyker vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Är det så att det är omständigheterna som styr mycket, alltså yttre omvärldsfaktorer som styr hur folk mår, det är inte hur folk är och tänker som styr?
Ja alltså, vad är viktigast, det är en bil, motorn eller däcken.
Du behöver bägge två va?
Det är samma sak här.
Vi människor, vi är ju på ett visst sätt, hanterar saker och problem på ett visst sätt.
Man brukar säga såhär, det är inte hur vi har det utan hur vi tar det.
Och just nu så har vi det tuffare än vanligt, men vi tar det också tuffare eftersom vi har varit ganska förskorna och har runnat en ganska lång tid ifrån bajset så att säga.
Och nu kommer allt på en gång och när jag är utiför det så brukar jag säga såhär att det är jättemycket grejer som hänger kvar från förr va?
Skolan och jobb och föräldrar och massa sånt här.
Häftigt.
Sen kom det ett litet litet virus som kastade om världen som vi kände till.
Det var första gången i våran livsstil så var det farligt.
På riktigt farligt.
Och som drabbade alla.
Det var inte ett litet utbrott utan någonting i centrala afrikanska republikan utan det var nu är det här liksom och det gick fort.
Lagom till det tar slut så är det ändå en liten farbror i Ryssland som får feeling och ska upprätta sovjettingens forna glans och där är vi igång va.
Så det här är a wicked combination utav många saker men det är inget nytt.
Det som är nytt är att det accelererar väldigt fort.
Okej.
Så kan man säga.
Ja.
Jag fattar, jag fattar.
Men nu hoppar vi bara rakt in.
Kör, kör, kör.
Men jag tänker att vi ska bara komma tillbaka så folk får någon sorts kontext här.
Kan du inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Kan vi inte börja där och bara, vem är Björn?
Björn är...
Björn Rudman heter jag.
Och jag jobbar som terapeut.
För innan stressar jag till hela psykisk ovälsning.
Men jag började inte där.
Utan innan det här så jobbade jag med långtidssmärta.
Smärtrehabilitering i stort sett uterslutande.
Och när man jobbar med smärta så måste du jobba med stress.
Du har inget val.
För att smärta är en upplevelse som sker i hjärnan.
Inte ut i ryggen eller i handen.
Utan det går en varningssinal ifrån vävnaren in till ryggnärgen, det är den här trådarna.
Skickas upp i huvudet där den tolkas.
Den tolkas bland annat på grund av mer smärta då.
Eller mer stress, stress i ett beredskapssystem kan man säga.
Ju högre beredskap det här, ju snabbare ska det få ont.
Och beredskapssystemet ska ju hålla oss ifrån fara.
Funkar det inte tvärtom också?
Jo, smärta är en stress.
Precis, och det är såhär, nu hoppade vi igen.
Haha, fucking, vi kommer att hoppa mycket i denna.
Det är såhär, stress i ett beredskapssystem.
Det är alltså, om du tänker det brandlarmet hemma, så är liksom stressen i hela brandlarmet.
Men i brandlarmet så finns det olika funktioner.
Dels är det en klocka som ringer, det är när larmet går, det är det vi kallar för det sympatiska nösystemet, fight-or-flight-systemet.
Nu är det panik, nu slåss vi.
Och det är ett hormon som driver den grejen, och det är ju det hormonet känner du till som adrenalin då.
Men det finns en funktion innan det, som man kan säga är sensorn i brandlarmet, och den kallas för HPA-axeln.
HPA-axeln är tre stycken körtlar som driver ut en hormonkarskal som ska förbereda beredskapen, som ska sätta igång vaksamheten i brandlarmet för att den snabbare ska kunna slå på.
HPA-axeln är kortisol som är huvudmoment i den.
För kortisol ska gå in i muskelcellerna, dra ut det lagrade sockeret så att du har energi till när du ska slåss eller fly.
Den här HPA-axeln behöver du inte vara skrämd för att den ska starta.
Utan den startar på mycket, mycket mindre grejer.
Det vill säga ett e-mail som du inte vill ha, en jobbig tanke om att du inte duger lika mycket som alla andra men inte du överpresterar.
Tanken av att allandras behov är viktigare än dina och du får vila när det är klart men inte innan dess.
Ekonomi, saker som inte är livshotande höjer beredskapen.
Så det höjer HPA-axeln, så därmed ökar beredskapen.
Det är också den här HPA-axeln man tror blir fucked up efter en utbrändighet, efter en utmattning.
Eftersom stresskänsligheten är så tydlig för väldigt många så är det där man tror i förklaringen.
När man har ont i kroppen till exempel så är det farligt.
Det är en överlevnadsproblematik för kroppen.
Om du har ont i ryggen så kan inte du slåss.
Du kan inte sparka om du har ont i knä till exempel, det funkar inte.
Alltså ska stressen drivas upp för nu är det mer farligt att vara människa.
Så ja, det hänger ihop och det går i bägge håll.
Men som sagt, jag jobbade som terapeut.
Jag jobbade med långtidssmärta innan.
Steg innan dess var det bara fysisk träning.
Personligt PT-träning och elitidotsträning, främst inriktade på kampsport.
Mot kickboksning?
Ja, kickboksning, tagboksning, vanlig boksning, taekwondo, de stående kampidotterna blev mina.
För att?
Jag har tränat kick och tag som 98.
Och är väl också helikroppen motsvarande.
Ja, jag förstår.
Kan man säga.
Vilken nivå höll du?
Du är ju en reslig kar så att säga.
Ehm, alltså som egen tävlar när det var väldigt många år sedan.
Men som tränare så var det ju landslagsnivå överallt egentligen.
Ehm, hade, när det var så mest intensiva så tror jag det var åtta landslag samtidigt.
Alltså inte med i landslagsorganisationen utan atleter ifrån åtta olika idrott liksom.
Var assisterande förbundets kapten i taggboksningslandslaget, var involverad i kippboksningslandslaget länge.
Även förbunden och så där liksom.
Men jobbade du både med det fysiska då och det psykiska?
Nej faktiskt inte, då var det mest fysiskt.
Ehm, och det var så hårt inriktat på just den fysiska prestationen.
Ehm, och skademekaniken då liksom.
Hur kan du röra på dig, kan du inte röra på dig?
Jag kommer en bokstad och säger att han har ont i axeln.
Så har vi problem.
Då är det inte mycket som går att göra med honom.
Om man säger va.
Ehm, utan då får vi börja med det först och så får vi sitta och träna runt i andra under tiden.
Ehm, utan det var först senare.
Det kom in mer och mer folk till företaget som hade ont.
För du drev någon sorts center då?
Ja, det var ju center och center.
Vi var en lokal liksom.
Ehm, en kampsportsdel och sen en gymmedel.
Ja, vi har för övrigt den här grejen i podden att här får man bara skryta.
Här behöver man inte vara hambol och ödmjuk så att vi kallar det för ett center liksom.
Det var dit folk vallfärdade.
Ja, vi hade ett litet ställe där liksom.
Folk kom och gick liksom.
Sen när de var Thai-boxing-profs eller om de var glada amatörer, det var inte så noga liksom.
Jag skiter mycket i det.
Men det var väldigt intensiva år i alla fall.
Och så kom det fler som var skadade och så löste vi det.
Jag startade företag 2012.
2014 anställde jag en kille som var sjukgynnast och så började vi jobba mer med rehab än så.
Men helt plötsligt så löste vi skador som sagrenskar inte fixade.
Vi fick in patienter som bara hade skador, ingenting annat.
Men de hade också en idrottsprofil.
De hittade oss genom idrottsspåret, träningsspåret.
Men så hade de uppfattat att vi fixar skador också.
Och så vi fattar inte hur kommer det sig att två grabbar i Säverdalen och industrilokaler löser det som sagrenska sryggexperter inte fixar.
Och när vi börjar kolla på vad det var vi gjorde så visar sig att det inte är vad vi gör, utan det är vad vi säger.
Hur får vi individen till att göra det som vi vet behöver göras?
Hur får vi compliance som det heter, alltså som alla tränare, telepefter har problem med.
Hur får man individen att göra som du vet att de behöver göra?
Hur tar de hem detta och gör det här?
Ska vi säga att det är den största frågan inom hela coachpersonligt träning och för läkare också.
Det är väl många som inte tar medicin.
Vad gör man då?
Först och främst är det så här, och jag tror också att det är någonting som träningsbranschen har behövt att smaka lite på.
Inom den terapeutiska delen, terapeutibranschen, så pratar man om den terapeutiska alliansen.
Det är du och jag mot problemet.
Det är inte du, ditt problem och sen är det jag.
Utan det är du och jag mot problemet.
Kan man hitta ett narrativ, som det heter va, där det blir så, så kommer det att funka.
Det handlar alltså om personkemi i grunderbotten.
Hur får du människorna att kika på det du säger?
Hur uttrycker du dig?
Hur pratar ni?
Sådana här saker.
Och där har jag ju haft en fruktansvärd fördel, eftersom jag har varit i sociala media ganska länge.
Jag började ju redan 2013 med filmer på Facebook, när Facebook krigar med YouTube och släpper upp alla filmer helt organiskt.
Jag hade ju alltså stora sexsiffriga belopp per mobilsnutt redan 2013.
Så jag har ju haft en fördel, om man kan lyssna på poddarna, hundratals avsnitt framlänge så baklänge så är det flera stycken poddar.
Man kan kolla på Instagram, det finns överallt va?
Så när människor kommer till mig så har de bestämt sig för att jag är det de behöver ha, och då gör de vad jag ber dem om.
Om jag förvaltar det ansvaret så kommer det här att gå bra.
Men vad menar du?
Hur hade ett sjukhus kunnat ta till sig av det eller hur hade...
Ja då har vi ju en annan problematik då, de har ju inte de resurserna, de kan ju inte hantera patienten under den tiden som det är det behövs för att lära känna dem.
Jag skulle nog kunna säga såhär, om jag fick 15, 20, 30 minuter med en människa, då är jag ganska hemma, men inte säkert.
Det kan ju vara en person som jag är helt okänd för och jag är den absolut skummaste människan jag någonsin har träffat.
För så är det, det funkar så liksom med människor.
Sjukhusen har ju inte den här resurserna, de har ju inte haft det på många år och det är ju så svagt idag så att det liknar ju grisen.
Det är ju knappt, vissa vårdinstanser, det är ju frågan om vi ens kan benämna det som vård.
Fattar du?
Du behöver ha den rapporten och den förståelsen att du ska tillbaka till den människan.
Ja och därmed hade det ju hjälpt att få träffa samma person till exempel.
Då hade det här ju skett över tid.
Då hade vi inte varit beroende av första mötet.
Men träningsbranschen så att säga, som har, om vi kollar den personliga träningen till exempel, världens bästa läge liksom, en konsultation redan där, pang, klickar vi eller klickar vi inte?
Vad är hon för person, vad är hon inte för person?
Vad är det hon behöver, vad är det han, hur uttrycker han sig?
Vad är det han verkar tycka är roligt, vad har han för intresse, vad kickar han på, vart får jag igång honom att prata om?
Kan använda liksom metaforer som han förstår.
Men upplever du det som att det viktiga är att ni skapar en rapport och en känsla tillsammans, eller är det viktigt att personen upplever en respekt, att de ska rapportera till det, att de har gjort rätt?
Nej, den önsesida respekten, om det blir en sådan sak där de måste göra rätt, då är det gott om de situationerna liksom, och då måste vi ta hand om det, för det är inte syftet.
Syftet är att du ska må bra.
Syftet är att du ska få träningsresultat, inte att du ska blicka mig.
Och det måste man göra klart väldigt tidigt.
Och det säger jag till mina patienter, för att du vet vännen, hos mig så kan du inte göra fel.
Vadå man är...
en prestation du vet, det är ju bra.
För det är en väldigt vanlig förekommande problematik i stressutmattning.
Det är perfectionism liksom, prestationsångest.
Och så säger jag såhär, men vet du vad, du har fått en övning utav mig, du har fått en sak du ska genomföra hemma.
Så kommer du tillbaka till mig och så har det inte gått.
Då är jag jätteintresserad av att veta varför har det här inte gått?
Vad var det som kom i vägen?
Vad var det som gjorde att det här blir bortprioriterat?
Vad var det som gjorde att det här som vi har pratat om, som du också vet behövs?
Hur kommer det sig att det inte funkade?
Och så tar vi reda på det.
Så vi bryter ner det och tar reda på beståndsdelarna för att kunna komma förbi och komma vidare nästa gång.
Jag får ju ut mer utav det egentligen än jag får utav en perfekt utförd mental övning.
För då vet jag att, okej men här har man försökt, man har inte lyckats, vi behöver hitta ett annat sätt att lyckas på.
Så att det är hela tiden den där finger topp känslan att känna in personen.
Vad är det jag har framför mig?
Vad är grejen liksom?
För alla har ju sin historia.
Alla har ju sina, alltså när ljuset är släckt hemma och dörren är stängd så har alla ungefär samma demoner liksom.
Det spelar ingen roll om du är översyrog eller om du är städare.
Det ser ungefär likadant ut.
Människor kommer ju därifrån de kommer så att säga.
De har ju med sig sin ryggsäck in i ett samtal eller in i ett PT case eller in i liksom ett affärs samarbete.
Hur funkar det?
Men man går inte att prata med den personen.
Det är dött när vi är ut och äter lunch.
Det är inte den första personen jag har i pipelineen när jag ska handla något.
Men den personen som är väldigt social och som man kan se fram emot och träffa och som engagerar sig, som ställer rätt frågor och som inte slutar eller bara väntar på sin tur och får berätta sin skit.
Det är en person som har byggt helt annat momentum med.
Det är en allians där också.
Och det är det tror jag många tappar att även om det kommer en person att ge dig en klump med pengar, hej, få mig i form, så är det egentligen inte det de är ut efter i grund och botten, utan de vill ha en riktning och de vill ha en bollplank.
Så det var lite det du förstod att ni var duktiga på?
Ja, och vi dokumenterade det.
Vi dokumenterade oss själva och tog reda på vad det är vi gör för något.
Sen var det så att vi blev så effektiva att vi tömde i princip marknaden i Göteborg.
Om du tänker en vinduttorkare.
Det fanns marknad åt ena hållet, men det finns ingen marknad åt andra hållet.
Det var helt privat, jag har inte anslutit in i något landsting.
Det innebär att du måste ha lite deg för att kunna komma till mig.
När du har ont på den nivån som vi jobbade med, har du också varit sjukskriven.
Då finns det inte de pengarna.
Vi såg att stress blir mer och mer.
I många fall kan vi skita i övningarna.
För det är inte en gummibandsövning till att du behöver.
Du behöver någon som frågar dig om du har det hemma.
Det var vad vi behöver.
När jag insåg att det här är en hållbarare modell, så ställde jag om kommunikationen digitalt.
Vi pratade mer om stress.
På den lägen var det.
Lyckades du hitta ett intresse i det?
Det var inte där du började.
Jag höll emot jättelänge.
Jag förstod att det här var någonting som jag skulle kunna göra.
Fast då ville jag inte.
För jag ville liksom inte ha, som jag kände då, den psykiska unga ohälsan hos mig.
För jag trodde att det skulle bli jobbigt.
Men så är det en situation där jag...
Men då var det träningsklient fast det blev liksom terapi patientet av det.
En situation där jag får välja.
Antingen så viker jag nu eller så står jag kvar.
Och jag står kvar och det har jag gjort sedan dess liksom.
Så jag höll emot jättedänga.
Men när jag väl släppte den spärren så var det liksom bara åka.
Och idag är det helt galet.
Jag gör absolut ingen marknadsföring för min egna terapi men det är fullt hela tiden.
Och jag tar rätt bra betalt så att det är ingen som bryr sig.
Och det blir utveckling i det också till slut.
Så just den biten, det var ett medvetet val just då.
Hur jobbar man när man jobbar på hög nivå som terapeut eller som med folks hjärna, eller vad jag ska säga.
Hur gör man själv för att hålla?
Behöver du hela tiden lägga steget före eller behöver du bara förstå hur går din lärande process för att kunna följa med?
Det är en ganska långtgående process som jag håller på hela tiden och framförallt har jag hållit på i många år tidigare.
Just med att lyssna och höra vad de säger.
Det är väl en av mina hyperfokusområden med ADHD, det är att förstå vad individer säger mellan raderna när de uttrycker sig.
Sen pusslar min hjärna väldigt effektivt och väldigt snabbt.
Så jag får ihop bilden ganska mycket tidigare än vad patienten får ihop den och då kan jag bara lasttesta, jag kan testa den emot patienten med olika frågor och olika resonemang.
Då får många upplevelsen att det är som att jag läser tankar, fast det går såklart inte.
Utan jag bara pusslar och de har tagit om för mig hur den här bilden ska se ut, fast de vet ofta inte det själva innan då.
Sen är det olika terapeutiska inriktningar som hjälper oss med olika saker egentligen, fast terapi som sådant ska ju terapia bort någonting dåligt.
Så att en del är de terapeutiska insatserna, det är om man kanske vill förändra ett negativt beteende, eller ett beteende som inte hjälper dig framåt eller som du tycker är jobbigt att ha.
Men den andra delen som minns lika viktigt är ju din person, du som människa, och det skiter ju KBT i, det skiter ju psykodynamik, alltså allt det här.
Utan du måste veta vem är du, vart vill du någonstans, vad har du för behov i vardagen och livet, vad är det du vill med detta liksom, hur har du det nu och vart vill du vara, vem är du själv liksom.
Det här är någonting som i regel inte finns hos psykologer och sånt, utan där tar man hand om problemet typ tio gånger, och så försöker man det bästa som går och sedan är det bra.
Fast det är ju bara en liten del av pusslet liksom.
Så det gäller ju att ha hela bilden med sig hela tiden, och se vart är människan på väg, vad är det som är jobbigt och så vidare.
Just inlärningen där, det går liksom i sjuk, man springer på en information, okej men det här är vettigt.
Och så läser man lite mer om makes sense, det stämmer överens med det andra jag kan.
Och så börjar man testa att kan det här resonemanget fungera, pang säger det, så hittar man en väg till på jättemånga utav ens patienter, för det blir ju ofta en ganska homogen grupp, speciellt om man är så nychad som jag är.
Så det är många gånger jag säger ungefär samma saker, flera gånger om dagen, fast på olika sätt, för olika öron, olika kontext, olika situationer, olika hemmaförhållanden, olika bakgrunder.
Är du någonsin rädd att du leker lite inception med folkstankar?
Nej, det är inte, hypnos fungerar, men det krävs ganska mycket just för dem, om man ska fixa det i stunden.
Sedan så är det ju så här att alla verkligheter är subjektiva.
Din verklighet är från ditt håll helt subjektiv.
Den ser inte ut som min, den ser inte ut som frugans.
Den är bara din va?
Och alla subjektiva verkligheter går att förändra.
Det kan man bara tänka sig.
Du träffar en person så tycker du en sak om den här personen första gången.
Men tionde gången så har det här förändrats.
Eller en smak du lär dig tycka om med tiden.
Då har också den subjektiva uppfattningen utav verkligheten förändrats.
Det är väl det någonstans som man är utöfte terapeutiskt.
Det här vi börjar med att säga, det är inte hur du har det utan hur du tar det.
Hur du har det är ju en subjektiv upplevelse.
Den kan jag förändra.
Hur du tar det kan jag också förändra.
Jag kan påverka dina tankar att det här är inte så farligt Johan.
Det här du är jätteorolig för här borta.
Titta nu på hur det ser ut.
Titta på hur faktan och verkligheten ser ut i det här.
Har det någonsin hänt det här du är orolig för?
Nej.
Finns det någonting i den här situationen som tyder på att det ska gå så åt helvete som du tror?
Okej, så det har aldrig hänt och det är väldigt osannolikt att det här händer.
Ja, precis.
Hur känns det nu?
Ja, den är inte lika farlig.
Pang.
Jag har förändrat din subjektiva uppfattning om problemet här borta.
Och det är det vi är ut efter för rent terapéftiskt.
Men jag vill ju att patienten själv ska göra detta.
De ska inte behöva mig, de ska inte behöva någon jävel i sina liv för att de mår bra.
Utan de ska klara sig själva.
Och då måste någon lära dem hur man gör.
Någon måste visa hur det här går till.
Då måste man ha bakgrund, man måste förstå hur lång tid kommer det här att ta.
Vad gör jag när det inte funkar?
Varför funkar det inte?
Ja men det var för att du var mer sårbar då.
Du har inte ätit, du har inte sovit och du har bråkat med henne hemma.
Okej, det här är anledningen till att katastrofen blir större idag.
Förra veckan så var det här inget problem, men nu är det jättestort, det blir jättefarligt.
Varför?
Jo, för att du är annorlunda idag.
Vi pratade ju lite om det här innan då, som sagt vem avsnittet är för idag, eller vem vi riktar in oss på.
Och det är ju, många av dem som lyssnar är folk som driver bolag i tränningsbranschen, eller som är hyggligt ansvariga på någon arbetsplats inom den här branschen.
Och säg att man är en sån här människa som, du kommer inte leva i balans, vilket ingen människa gör väl.
Men du är liksom inställd på att, faktiskt det här kommer vara 15-20 år som är rätt tunga.
Hur ställer man in huvudet och hur ska man jobba för att kunna hantera det utan att bryta ihop på bästa sätt?
Jag tänker spontant så, så 15-20 år så kommer det att bryta ihop.
Ja.
Fair enough då.
Jag tänker såhär, jag är helt med på hur du menar.
Och det är så i vissa perioder så finns det inte balans.
Det går inte som entreprenör att ha balans då.
Och så har jag också det.
Det är en sådan period nu.
Det har varit det sen i november.
Både på hemmaplan och i arbetet, det händer så mycket grejer som är på gång.
Så just nu så är det liksom damage control nästan.
Och det är lite så man får jobba under de perioderna så måste man, man får gå upp i någon form jag brukar kalla det för stadsläge.
Du behöver hitta de här funktionerna som du verkligen måste ha för att ha näsan ovanför vattnet utan.
Och då börjar man ju alltid med sömn.
Så, prior 1, 2, 3, 4 och 5.
Du måste sova.
Och då får vi kanske under den här perioden gå och lägga oss tidigare och sova så länge vi kan.
Det är en del.
Den andra delen är ju att vi måste äta.
Har vi inte mat i oss, energi i oss så kan vi aldrig någonsin få energi.
Det går inte, det funkar inte på det viset.
Och den tredje delen tänker jag då är att omsätta den här energin, det vill säga träning.
Det behöver röra på oss, punkt.
Och det var ingen fråga.
Utan träning är ju en hobby.
Man får ta bort den grejen.
Träning är lika viktigt som att andas för någon som är högpresterande.
Någon som pressar väldigt hårt för att man behöver det, för att det är en uppstartsperiod, för att man har ett bolag, man måste ta på sig blåbyxorna.
Men du kan inte göra det också ovanpå allt annat.
Du kan inte ligga på sexans växel i en bil och sen försöka öka.
Det går inte.
Någonting kommer att gå sönder.
Ja, och antagligen så är det du.
Jag personligen går sönder i kroppen.
Jag går inte sönder i huvudet.
Jag har jobbat med diabetes typ 2 2017 på grund av en sån här situation.
Jag gillar att du har jobbat dig till.
Du förtjänade det.
Ja, men det var ju lite så alltså.
Andra går sönder kognitivt va?
För det går inte.
Den här HPA-axeln ni pratar om, brandlarmet, det kan liksom inte larma hela tiden.
De största faktorerna innan man börjar jobba med psyket är att få sömn mat och träning på plats.
Ja, alltså jag skulle säga så här, det är inte antingen eller, utan det här är samtidigt.
Det är hjulen och motorn igen.
Det här är en viktig del och sen då den fjärde delen som jag brukar nämna, du måste göra saker i livet som är roligt.
Det var heller ingen fråga.
Du kan inte bara ha jobb, press, jobb, press, jobb, press, hemma, press, jobb, press, hemma.
Utan du måste ha något som kan ge dig energi, så att du kan tanka.
Och det är inte helt lätt om man har kört rejset länge, för det är väldigt mycket som passerats ut i perforin.
Ju mer du presterar, ju mer mätbara mål du går på, att det är det enda som får din självkänsla till att må lite göttig om du har levererat ett resultat.
Men det räcker inte att du är du, och du har ett gött samtal med en polare.
Det räcker inte för att du ska känna att det kickar för dig.
Då börjar vi få problem.
Så de här sakerna, sömn, mat, träning, och om man inte har en utmattningsproblematik så är det ganska hård träning vi är utövda efter.
Vi behöver pressa pulsen.
Vi behöver lyfta tungt.
Vi behöver fysa tungt.
Varför är det viktigt?
Sömn är väldigt logiskt och mat är väldigt logiskt.
Vad är det i träning som gör att vi...
Om träning hade funnits i ett litet blått pillar så hade alla i världen ätit det.
Men om vi ska gå en promenad varje dag, absolut.
For break even ja.
För att organen ska funka och för att hjärnan typ ska få det vad den behöver.
Men en ökad ämnesomsättning kommer också öka.
En ökad energiomsättning i huvudet.
Hjärnan kommer att kunna använda mer bränsle.
Syrupptagningsmågan kommer att göra att blodet är syrrikare.
Vi kan sänka pulsslagen eftersom hjärtatslagvolym ökar.
Alltså driver ut mer blod per slag.
Alltså du får en fysisk mycket mer fördelaktig funktion, en fysiologi i kroppen, som både skyddar hjärnan mot stress, men också hjälper den att processa.
Den hjälper den att fungera.
Och nu blir det också lite krångligt så här.
Våra kognitiva förmågor, alltså minnekoncentrationsmågor sådana, är uppbyggt utav någonting som heter exekutiva funktioner, alltså sätta igång funktioner.
Om man är trött och däven så funkar de funktionerna mycket sämre.
Mycket, mycket sämre.
När du är trött, du har sovit risigt en natt, så vet du att du inte är skarp.
Men om hjärnan alltid är sån, oavsett hur du har sovit eller inte, så har vi problem.
Och den blir åt det hållet om vi är inaktiva.
Men den går åt andra hållet om vi är fysiskt aktiva.
Så tyngre träning är en bra sak.
Och då får vi också en direkt stressreglerande funktion där.
För träning driver upp stresssystemet, det ska det göra.
Men när träningen slutar, så kommer det också systemet få signal att sluta nu då.
Och då gör det det.
Och därför kan du plana ut efter det.
Tillsammans då med endorfiner som är kroppens egna morfin, som gör att det känns väldigt gött och väldigt bra.
Det är som extremt positiva funktioner och spiraler vi får utav träningen.
Men det räcker ju inte med ett pass.
Utan, hade det varit en stressutmattningssituation så hade jag sagt lite varje dag.
Klart mycket bättre än två grispass i veckan.
Men om man inte har det så varannan dag liksom.
Lite tuffare.
Kanske en blandning mellan, kör stryka i cykelform kanske, det är en favorit jag har.
Och sen avsluta med någon rent konditionspressande, en kodivaskulär, par minuter, och sen är du hemma liksom.
In, fack, kärra, live.
Alltså det ska gå fort va.
Och sen är du klar.
That's it.
Det viktiga är att det blir av och att man inte ger sig.
Och att det här är minst lika viktigt som att andas liksom, som att äta.
Jag tänker bara till de som driver ett gym här och lyssnar, de kan sno den sloganen från dig och skicka en faktura sen.
Men fack, kärra, live.
Det är en bra slogan.
Jajaja, visst.
Alltså kort, smack, in, ut.
Perfekt.
Och så sätta en plotindrink i näden på den när man går, så är vi hemma liksom.
Du pratade om stabsläge.
Ja.
Vad vill du utveckla, vad du menar med det?
Jo, men stabsläge, om man kollar i samhället så är ju det organisationer går upp i en viss typ av annan organisation.
Man skalar bort allt lullul och gör bara det som är centralt och viktigt.
Och det tänker jag är samma sak i människan när man har en tuff period.
Det kan vara alltså, det behöver inte vara så allvarligt.
Tänk att vi går in i Vabuari.
Ja, jag har precis varit hemma en månad, eller tjejen också.
Då ungarna roterar på grissjuk liksom.
Ja, det är så.
Då kan vi inte göra allt som vi gjorde tidigare.
Vi kommer att vara tröttare.
Vi kommer antagligen själva bli sjuka eftersom vi ligger så nära infektionskällan.
Ja, men då gör vi så under en period.
För att kunna hantera det som är centralt och viktigt.
Och sen så ska ju den lugna sig.
Ja, hur länge kan du ligga i stadsläge?
När märker du att du är för länge i stadsläge?
Alltså jag tänker så här, om man går upp i den grejen och inte ser ett tydligt slut på det.
Jag menar, en infektion tar slut.
Barnen kommer att befriska, du kommer att befriska.
Men på jobbet, om man har besvär med likvida medel, om man har en obalanserad ekonomi, om det är problem med leveranskedjor och sånt så är det inte alls säkert det är frågan om stadsläge, utan det kanske är det nya normala.
Då behöver organisationen formas efter det, inte efter att permanenta ett stadsläge.
Jag gillar det som tumregel, om man märker att det finns ett slut, då kan man på något sätt hantera det.
Om du ser slutet i horisonten, att vi vet att det kommer att vara så här nu, som i er fall då, när vi får den leveransen, då vet vi att nu är vi hemma.
För då är det här, då kan vi börja omsätta det här till försäljning.
Okej, vad gör vi fram till dess?
Och fram till dess får vi ta in pengarna där vi kan, och vi ser också konstant över kostnadsbilden.
Kan vi klippa någonting nu?
Kan vi pausa något?
Har vi stålbadat klart eller är vi nöjda?
Sådär.
Och hitta ett sånt läge under tiden.
Men det kan ju inte vara det permanenta.
Hur hanterar du, låt oss säga, vi är ju precis vid en lekplats här, vi är med oss och spelar in.
Då pratar man ju med föräldrar, säger att vi har ett par här som har haft kolik i ett år, samtidigt som det är tufft på jobbet.
Det är klart att det någon gång tar slut, men det tar ju aldrig slut i huvudet.
Hur hanterar man en sån situation mentalt?
Det är ju samma för föräldrar till barn med JMPF.
Det tar aldrig slut.
Det kan jag bekräfta också, det tar inte slut tonåren heller.
Det blir värre.
Och det är en situation, det är den du har.
Hur hanterar man när du vet att du ska befinna dig i en tuff situation som du inte hade räknat med?
Jag tänker lite olika saker.
Dels så kommer jag att grotta ner mig i det här, tycker att det är jävligt tråkigt och synd och dumt ett tag.
Och det är en del i processen, jag kan kalla det för en sorgeprocess eller vad som helst.
Men snart kommer man också kunna komma fram till att såhär kan jag inte gå runt.
Jag kan inte sluta leva bara för att det är såhär.
Det finns inga möjligheter.
Men okej, så vad behöver jag för att hitta en lägsta nivå som faktiskt fungerar?
Kollar vi ett par med kolleg eller MPF, och det är ett barn, då tycker jag absolut att man ska ske med att lägga egen tid.
Idag är det din tid, idag är det min tid.
Okej, hur vill du ha det?
Jag är gärna ensam hemma idag.
Då går vi ut.
Då åker vi iväg en sväng.
Eller, jag åker gärna iväg idag.
Ja, gör det.
Att det finns en ömsesidig dialog, en harmoni i det där att båda parter behöver.
Det är också så att det är fullständigt mängelslöst att bägge föräldrar är trasiga hela tiden.
Det innebär att man tar varannan natt och den andra natten så sover man ut ordentligt och då rör man sig inte.
Oavsett vad som låter därute så rör man sig inte.
Man ligger kvar.
Det är ett sätt, om man kollar på den situationen och kolleg, småbarn, så är det när de kommer och blir klara.
Och det blir bättre ganska snabbt, ofta.
Helt plötsligt så sover barnet bra och så vågar man inte gingsa det som man säger inget.
Men barn med NPF det är inte så.
Utan där kommer skolan att vara kaos varje dag.
Där kommer det bli större problem och ju större barnet blir.
Och föräldrar till barn med NPF är ju våldsamt överrepresenterade i psykisk oavdrag.
Det är alltså 90 procent i förekomst nästan.
Och då är det ju så här.
Beroende på vilken situation som skapar problemen så hade jag, parallellt som jag tar hand om mig själv på det bästa sättet du kan, alltså sömn, mat, träning, precis den plattformen vi pratade om, baseline, så hade jag också tittat på vad kan jag göra för att stabilisera situationen hemma.
Och ett NPF-barn behöver rutiner.
Kan du säga vad NPF är?
NPF, ADHD, neuropsykiatriskt funktionsnedsättning, ADHD, ADD, autism.
De barnen behöver ramar och rutiner.
Så ju mer rutiner man har, ju bättre barnen vet hur allting funkar, desto lättare kommer situationerna att bli.
Så parallellt som man tar hand om sig själv, så får man också se till att stabilisera situationen så gott det går.
Nu var det bara ett exempel, nu var vi hemma i privatlivet, kollar vi yrkeslivet, kollar vi jobbet till exempel.
Okej men vad är det som kaosar?
Hur kan vi fixera den här situationen?
Vad är det som gör att det blir så här?
Är det personalrutinen som inte flyger?
Är det dålig kontroll på ekonomin som inte flyger?
Så vi pratade om förut, är det jag som människa som inne och petar i skit som jag inte vet mer om än vad personalen vet?
Ja men, köp det läget då, men det är jag som skapar de här grejerna.
På något sätt så kommer det gå att stabilisera situationen så att den tar mindre energi.
Och då är första steget som jag hade jobbat med patienter det är att göra en inventering av problemet.
Vad är det som händer?
Vad är det för fakta de har?
Vad är det som är fel?
Vad är hela grejen här?
Och sen bara okej, men vad är det jag faktiskt vet i detta?
Så kommer du att få stryka massa, för vissa saker tänker du, känner du, tycker du, fast det är helt orelevant nu.
Nu är det bara fakta.
Okej, det är det här vi vet.
Pappret talar om såhär.
Ja, det är ju för lite information för att veta någonting om det här.
Nej, bra, då vet du det.
Då är nästa steg att ta reda på mer om den här situationen.
Eller så ser du precis exakt varför det här inte funkar.
Och då vet du också vad du ska angripa.
Så baslinen, mat, sömn, träning, roliga grejer, det pågår hela tiden.
Och sedan med andra handen så får man försöka då stabilisera situationen.
Och ibland så när jag får in patienter, till exempel att föräldrar till en PF-barn som pratar om, jag bara, sover du?
Ja, jag däckar.
Bra, då skiter vi det.
Nu kolla här borta.
Er vardag.
Du berättade att morgonen är inferno.
Ja, det förstår jag att den är, sa jag.
För det är ingen som vet någonting där.
Då börjar vi där.
Och så går man steg för steg.
Vad är det?
Du har ju ändå en bakgrund då med idrottar och ändå ganska högt presterande människor och säkert de som har råd att betala för att gå sånt här har säkert bra jobb så de är säkert hyggligt intelligenta.
Det beror faktiskt på, det är jättemånga som, alltså från skoleomsorg.
Tyvärr är det så att människor fixar det ekonomiska för att komma till mig.
Ja, jag fattar, jag fattar.
Så jag har alla sorter, alltså jag har allt ifrån överläkare till förskolepersonal.
Ja, för det jag vill komma till någonstans är att folk förstår ju att de har ett problem och de förstår säkert också ganska ofta var problemet är.
Så vad är det som är så krångligt med att lösa problemet?
Varför kan vi inte lösa detta själva?
Varför måste vi komma till dig?
Det är en jättebra fråga och jag tänker att det är flera svar.
Eller det är mångbottnat på det här.
Dels är det så här att när en situation har pågått länge så är den vad man kallar för normaliserad.
Och normalisering låter snällt men det är det farligaste vi människor har.
För du kan alltså normalisera övergrepp, du kan normalisera missbruk, du kan normalisera alltså en miserabel tillvaro.
För att hjärnan gör det för att varje hemsk upplevelse, varje jobbig sak ska inte bli lika jobbig varje gång den händer.
Och då trubbar hjärnan av den och till slut så är det vardag.
Man bara rycker på axlarna och han sa så.
Ja men det gör han alltid.
Ja just det, han gör det alltid ja.
Och då har det blivit ett stort stort problem.
Och det här gör våra hjärnor även med trötthet, även med stressrelaterad psykisk ohälsa, men i alla situationer.
Ja men det har alltid varit såhär.
Så det känns inte tillräckligt dåligt för att ta tag i det fören det smäller.
Och det är därför många inte söker hjälp för den stressen faktiskt att bli fysisk.
Den emotionella stressen när det inte syns, när det inte känns, den väntar man ut in absurdum.
Men om du har börjat få ont i huvudet, om du har börjat få koncentrationsproblem, att du inte kan läsa, om du har fått yskel, om du har fått domningar i armar, händer, ben, ena, kinden försvinner, tryck över bröstet, ont i magen, you name it, då söker du hjälp.
Så det är först när stressen har blivit somatisk egentligen, eller fysisk, som man söker hjälp.
Så det är väldigt komplicerat.
Sen är det så här att det här är svåra saker.
Ett beteende som du alltid har gjort kommer du inte kunna bryta, bara hur som helst.
Vi går i kognitiva beteendespår, vilket innebär att du gör som du alltid har gjort.
Och det är en primitiv funktion, för vi skulle gå till samma ställe och hämta maten på savannen.
Vi skulle bli nervösa när det lät på ett visst sätt.
Eller när det luktade på ett visst sätt.
Så vi drillade under evolutionen att göra som vi alltid har gjort.
Och när vi då har gjort det här på ett sätt som dessutom har funkat.
Det har varit effektivt för dig att driva.
Och det var ju för dig med, du har plöjt som fan och byggt upp en jättegrej fram tills den dagen det inte gick längre.
Så helt plötsligt så är strategin som har tagit dig dit du har kommit, den är giftig nu.
Och då ska hjärnan förstå detta idag.
Och det går inte.
Så att det man hade behövt då, det är att börja tänka på sig själv, börja titta inåt, hur mår jag, hur känns det, vad har jag för energi, vad har jag för ork, hur orolig är jag för saker och ting och så vidare och så vidare.
Och om man känner då att det här är, det finns liksom ganska stora svar på att jag är orolig, eller jag har svårt att sova, eller jag ligger och ängslar mig över saker som jag inte kan styra över.
Jag har tryck över bröstet, jag börjar bli taggig, sådana här saker.
Att man tittar och umgås med sig själv och inser att det här är inte jag.
Det här är ju ett uttryck för någonting annat, det är så här det har blivit, men jag vill inte ha det så här.
Nej, bra, då vet vi.
Men det är alltså våldsamt svårt att göra den förändringen själv, en som ser den på grund av mycket normaliseringen som har skett under väldigt lång tid.
Och sen då när det väl inte funkar längre, då har ju hjärnan ingen aning om att det inte funkar.
Den tror ju att det är som det är förr.
Och då brukar jag säga så här, om du har spelat chack i hela ditt liv och så rätt som det så är det någon som över natten har bytt ut chackberädd, ett monopolberädde, vilket är ungefär det som händer vid utmattning.
Och du fortsätter att försöka spela chack.
Det är inte helt lätt att köpa någon man stormar en häst.
Det går liksom inte, det blir konstigt.
Och det är precis vad som händer så att spelet förändrar sig väldigt fort ibland och lite långsamt ibland, men det är inte samma som det alltid har varit, även om hjärnan försöker få det till att bli det.
Jag älskar det uttrycket normalisering i det här fallet, för det känns, jag kan verkligen se att många har fastnat i vad det är.
För det är ju ganska ofta så när man pratar med en polare eller något som har stora problem att, vafan, du ser väl vad du håller på med?
Du måste väl fatta detta.
Men, och säg då att det finns en sån normaliseringsprocess då, men, hur väljer man?
Går du in och grottar i alla de samtidigt eller tar du en i taget?
Det kan ju bli ganska kaosigt om du helt plötsligt öppnar upp huvudet för att, här var det mycket som inte var bra.
Ja, det stämmer.
Det finns ju en fördel att vara lite namn i huvudet i band mot vissa saker.
Det tror jag absolut, det finns en fördel i väldigt många fall att vara det.
Det är ju en sån gammal sanning att, ju mer intelligent du är, ju sämre mår du, så är det.
Hemmingway sa ju det också.
En lycklig, intelligent människa är det mest hälssynta jag vet.
För det är så.
Man behöver vara lite, lite som, lite gokorkad.
Lite gokorkad, perfekt.
Är det därför vi i Göteborg är lite gladare?
Ja, ja precis.
Vi har lite lägre IQ.
Ja, några procent lägre ja.
Jag är ju Kärnobirn-generationen, jag är 86a.
Och jag tänker att vi har lite gladare och bättre liv än andra.
För att det händer något.
Jag är från Luleå också, så det var mycket svamp och bär där.
Ja, du fick den.
Du fick radiumet bara smack.
Nej men det är ju så att jag rör ju inte allting på en gång.
Även om jag vet att det finns där, jag hör ju vad de berättar.
Och jag hör också mellan raderna.
Och jag har ju också gjort research i form av bedömningssamtal och för snack.
Att jag vet ungefär, till exempel om jag vet att det finns en tuff barndom så går jag inte in där nu.
Utan jag fokuserar alltid på att lösa problem.
Vilka problem ska jag hjälpa den här individen att lösa?
Och då är det nästan alltid så att vi ska gräva där vi står.
Vad är det som är jobbigast idag?
Och det kan vara olika från gång till gång.
Kommer de in vecka ett och så har de ett problem och så vecka fyra, men då har det ändrat sig.
Nu är det här som är det stora problemet istället.
Ja, det är så det funkar.
De kommer ju säkert hänga ihop eftersom det sker i samma huvud och det är ungefär samma vibes på alla olika ställen.
Jag behöver ju inte ta allting på en gång, utan ofta väljer jag ut det jag hör är viktigast just nu.
Och då är det ju, vilken punkt kommer göra mest för individen att få ordning på?
Om vi jobbar till exempel med det jobbiga ordet acceptans som jag hör, att individen kämpar emot verkligheten hela hela tiden.
Om de inte hade gjort det så hade allt det här bra hänt.
Då kan jag ju släppa allt det som är dåligt, liksom i bakgrunden och fokusera på hur får jag individen till att köpa det som händer idag.
Så jag väljer, jag tar inte allting på samma gång, även om jag vet att det finns där, jag vet att det kommer.
Och sen när det är vissa situationer, ja, det var för jävligt, då vet vi det.
Har det gött?
Jag behöver inte in och bryta upp trauman.
Jag behöver inte hjälpa individen att återuppleva det.
Det räcker att jag vet det.
Det finns egentligen ingen anledning in och bända i det.
För det kommer ju att de mår sämre och det är jag inte riktigt intresserad av.
Det är inte alla, kolla traumabehandling och PTSD-behandling, den man brukar köra som heter Prolonged Exposure, det är ju att utsättas för det igen, fast i en trygg miljö.
Jag gillar inte det.
Jag tycker att det inte är värt.
Det finns en bra effekt på det, men det kräver också extrema insatser från patienten.
Då kan jag hellre hjälpa dem att ha det bra nu och hur jag ska hantera vågorna av obehag när de kommer.
Vi vet ju var de kommer ifrån, vi behöver inte.
Så det är lite olika där.
Men jag hade inte rört allting på en gång.
Du träffar ju folk som har en problematik på något sätt när du träffar dem.
Har du någonsin intresserat dig för eller undersökt folk som du inte träffar?
De som faktiskt mår bäst i samhället?
De som bara går runt och liksom, när jag har ett gött liv och jag trivs här och så är de glada, eller glada men säger att de är lyckliga.
Finns det någonting som sammanfattar människor som faktiskt lyckas leva liv som är fantastiska, rent subjektivt?
Ja, det gör det.
Jag tror såhär också att det är en vanlig missuppfattning att tro att det finns människor som inte har problem.
Även de har problem, fast på sina sätt.
Därmed är det inte sagt att de behöver ta hand om det.
Nu är det ju här, alltså de här problemen som jag jobbar med, de är så vanliga då att de finns nästan inte kvar.
Man kan se, det är liksom företagsledare som äger verksamheter själva som är väldigt väl ekonomiskt beställda.
De har ganska småproblem.
De mår inte lika dåligt som alla andra.
För att de styr över sina vardagar på ett helt annat sätt än vad människor som är arbetstagare gör till exempel.
De har inte samma krav, alltså konstanta kravställning.
Det är inte lika mycket som driver upp HPA-axeln.
Och jag tänker att de som jag träffar som mår bäst är de som har haft det värst.
De som har kommit igenom det.
De som, nej, det här är väl ingenting.
Jag var med om detta.
Det här är ingenting.
Och det är lite grann, jag kan dra en parallell där till våra idrottar.
Efter att gå åt match så är det inte mycket som rör oss i ryggen.
Men på måndagen efter fight, det finns ingen som kan påverka oss.
För vi gjorde en grej i lördags som ingen annan gör på det här stället.
Och jag vet att det finns ingen stress som kan påverka mig högre än på det sättet som jag var med om i lördags när jag skulle slåss mot en motståndare som var jätteduktig, väldigt väl förberedd.
Det var bara han och jag, en ring eller en bur och sedan domare och så som folk som stod runt omkring och ville att jag skulle ha hjärt honom eller han har hjärt mig.
Det finns ingenting som rör mig i ryggen överhuvudtaget.
Det är det vi har svårigheterna i livet för.
För vi får ju ut någonting bra av det också, de här kamperna.
Stålet måste brännas för att härdas.
Så kontrollerade svårigheter med en tidsram är bra för människan?
Ja det skulle jag absolut säga.
Och det är nog inte orsaken att vi svenskar mår så dåligt nu.
För vi har haft det väldigt lätt, väldigt länge.
Och vi tar bort kontrollerade svårigheter.
Ja exakt.
Och nu så kan vi inte göra det.
Och vi har inga resurser för att ta hand om det.
I då ett läge där samhället förändras och där vi mår sämre och sämre som population.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger ändå.
Jag har två småpojkar då.
Och de är i åldrar där de har börjat bråka mycket.
Du vet om de brottas och slår på varandra och sånt där.
Och min filosofi, jag får se om min flickvän lyssnar på detta sen, men min filosofi är i alla fall att låt dem bråka och puttas och dra och slås så länge de inte slår på varandra.
Du vet, allvarligt.
För att det är bra att man lär sig att förstå att det är okej att brottas och skojbråka.
Men så fort det blir ett slag mot ansiktet eller ett farligt slag, då blir det en sådan, stopp leken är slut, nu får ni gå till era rum, det här är inte aktuellt längre.
För att det är nyttigt att ha lite lite kaos och förstå att kaoset inte är så farligt.
Nu drar jag det jättelångt, men det är ju småbarns kaos.
Det är min filosofi.
Jag tänker att det är samma här.
Det är bra med svårigheter, så länge man inte går över gränsen till där det är farligt.
Ja, precis.
Jag tänker så här att...
Anmäl mig inte nu.
Nej, jag tänker så här.
Om vi kollar vuxna, så kommer det att hända svårigheter vad är så du vill det eller inte.
Så att det var ingen fråga om eller inte va.
Då är det viktigt att förstå att här kommer vi få ut bra utav detta också.
Så att det kommer en tid efteråt där det är väldigt mycket bättre.
Och där svårigheterna som vi tog oss igenom har gjort oss starkare.
Så är det.
Nu finns det ju också en gräns på hur mycket svårigheter en människa kan ta liksom och att det finns effekt.
Men man kan göra mycket med det där.
Och när det gäller barn så tänker jag så här att jag tänker ner på fysisk aktivitet.
Det är perfekt att de brottas liksom.
Eller håller på att kivas.
Och att man kanske hjälper dem med det.
Att så här brottas ni.
Men kolla här nu, nu hamnar han där över igen.
Jag skulle sagt att jag gjorde det på grund av den fysiska aktiviteten.
Jag har ju en matt där inne i barnrummet som vi drar fram och så brukar vi så brottas här.
Nu kör vi match och då är det såhär, du gör såhär, du gör såhär.
Först är den på rygg förloraren.
Nu kör vi.
Men det är ju så om man använder fysisk kraft för vingarargument, då är det ju också det som barnen kommer lära sig.
Så jag tycker absolut att de ska röra på sig, man får vara lite såhär, vad är det de håller dem på i den uppgörelse här nu, att jag har rätt och du har fel.
Och att om jag vinner så har jag rätt.
Så funkar det kanske inte riktigt i världen.
Och jag tänker också så att om det är mycket sånt så hade jag ju släppt in dem i en brottningsklubb.
Rätt av.
Nu är inte jag brottare, men hade jag börjat om mitt liv så hade jag sett till att börja en brottning så fort det gick.
För det är nog den idrotten som är överlägset bäst på att bygga fysisk kapacitet i hela vår värld.
Det borde finnas brottning och gympa på skolan.
Får jag in en brottare som atlet så kan jag bygga om den för siken till vad som helst och han är antagligen inte skadad.
För han är så stark att det är så omöjligt att göra sönder honom.
Så jag förstår precis vad du menar.
Jag tycker att det finns inget rätt och inget fel där.
Man har en uppfattning om vad syftet är.
Man får göra det i smyg när tjejer inte ser.
Nu ska jag säga, nu har pappa byggt också en octagon heter det här ute.
Nu har jag köpt åtta stycken sådana, vi heter kravallstaket och ställt upp här.
Det här är armbågsskydd.
Man ska inte skada armbågen.
Nej, skit så.
Vi ska inte hamna där.
Jag tänkte att vi ska också någonstans runda av oss en småning om här.
Vi sa det in.
Jag har kapat så mycket frågor idag ska jag säga.
Vad är det som jag sa då?
Det hade flera avslut.
Ja, jag kunde ha dragit två timmar till.
Men jag jobbade med viktminskning under många år till exempel och satt och lyssnade på folk.
Och till slut upplevde jag att jag själv blev en dålig coach för att jag bara liksom, jag var inte så intresserad längre.
Det blev liksom inte intressant att sitta och lyssna på folk som hade väldigt mycket liknande problem.
Men jag spesade ut.
Hur gör du för att upprätthålla din intresse?
Det blir också en respekt mot patienten att man faktiskt ska vara full in the moment.
Hur gör du för att stanna där och hitta intresset för människor på det sättet?
Jag tror så här, alltså dels med de här grejerna så är även om problemen är liknande, så är situationerna aldrig identiska.
Så det finns ju någonting unikt i varje.
Det finns ju en människa bakom varje problem som är fullständigt unik liksom.
Och de här sakerna som jag jobbar med även om faktan och vetenskapen är likvärdig som de behöver ha för att kunna lösa sina problem, så kan ju det förmedlas på väldigt många olika sätt.
Och de har ju mest av sina erfarenheter, de har ju mest av sina grejer liksom.
Och det jag kikar på det är ju när det funkar, alltså lösa, bryta upp problemet liksom så att de får en förbättring så att de känner, och då är det nästa steg och nästa steg och nästa steg.
Det är också väldigt ofta så att det är ju inte en rak linje, utan det händer grejer på vägen, vilket innebär att om en människa då inte har fått till det de ska göra hemma, då är det en helt egen unik situation som gjorde att hon inte kunde få till det här hemma.
Så att det blir egentligen inte tråkigt på det sättet.
Och sen är det ju, det här är ju en del av det jag gör liksom.
Sen är jag ju väldigt mycket, jag håller ju på med onlineutbildningar och jag spelar in content i sociala medier och skriver och sånt där.
Och håller på med det också.
Så att jag försöker hålla min dag så varierande som möjligt för att inte hamna där.
Nu har det blivit så de senaste åren i alla fall.
Jag upplever att vi tänker olika, jag är alltid intresserad av att människor har olika tankemönster men min bana är väldigt mycket, jag målar upp scenarion och så rör jag mig längs de olika scenarierna bortåt.
Du låter när du lyssnar på folk mer som att du sitter och pusslar och gör någon sorts knä, du untangle the knot lite mer.
Absolut.
Så funkar inte riktigt min tankeprocess.
Jag kan förstå att du är mer intresserad av att sitta.
Jag kan se hur vi tänker olika i detta.
Absolut, jag tycker det är superintressant för precis som du säger, man kommer inte med med ett nystan utan ändar.
Det första jag gör det är att hitta en ende.
Och ofta sådana, men det finns ingen ende.
På mitt nystan så finns det ingen ende.
Okej, men då är det helt unikt och det tror jag inte på.
Så låt mig titta lite här, oj där var ett hörne bra, det du inte hade sa du.
Och här var det andra.
Och sen började vi.
Jag tror att det är ett nyttigt tankesätt för folk att ha som ska jobba med människor, att se det på det sättet.
Ja, jag tror att det är en viktig del i alla fall.
Sedan så är det ju så här att man har även nytta utav den här lite fyrkantiga approachen också i vissa delar.
Framförallt ska jag säga vardagsstruktur.
För om vi kollar stressutmattning till exempel så är det arbetsterapi som är överlägset bäst för det.
För det är där lösningen ligger.
Ska vi bli bra från utbrändhet eller utmattning så måste vi minska belastningen, vi måste öka återhämtningen.
Och hur minskar vi belastningen?
Jo, genom struktur.
Genom att se över hur vardagen ser ut, genom att göra ett schema så du vet hur mycket du förbrukar, när du ska vila, vad du ska göra, allt det här.
Det här är fasigt.
Då behöver vi verkligen, verkligen, verkligen förmågan att följa en linje och skapa ett mönster.
Och där vill ju jag att patienten själv är med och skapar, för jag kan inte göra det för dem, jag lever ju inte hemma hos dem.
Så det är någonting som är svårt för de allra flesta.
Så det behövs både också, definitivt.
Och det är jätteintressant just med hur man är som person.
Man använder ju sig själv som verktyg.
Och det är därför som inte jag håller i min hjärna, så blir det ju inte bra.
Säg att man vill börja syssla inom den här världen och börja jobba med människor, men man vill inte bara peta därinne utan man vill faktiskt bli fullbokad och man vill få ut en lön så att man faktiskt kan leva på detta.
Du har ju nämnt sociala medier, du har ju nämnt poddar, du har ju skrivit en bok, du kanske har skrivit flera böcker, men du får ta alla namn av den här sedan i slutet.
Men hur når man ut till människor?
Hur blir man duktig?
Hur får man en kundstock?
Jag tänkte på det när jag åkte hit, för det är en av frågorna du skickade över till mig innan, och det är en väldigt intressant fråga.
När jag jobbar med företagsorganisationer, ibland är det så att jag får företagsledare, och så hör jag direkt att ja men din organisation är ju här i chaparall, det är klart att du togs stressar, vi måste kolla på det här.
Ja, jag har bara kört, ja, jag ser det.
Lantbruket är ju sådant till exempel, jag har jättemycket lantbrukare, det finns ju inget, inte papper skrivet om någonting någonstans.
Jag brukar alltid göra någonting som heter business model canvas, som är, jag vet inte vilka det är som gjort den från början, men det heter utsystem, en struktur där man liksom spesar upp, vad har du för värdebjudande till marknaden, vad har du för kunnsegment, hur ser intäktsflödet ut, vad har du för samarbetspartner, vad har du för nyckelaktiviteter, allt det här så man kan få ut det på ett papper.
Då får man börja med att spesa, vad är det du ska erbjuda marknaden?
Vad är det som behövs då?
Då får man titta lite, man får googla, kolla, man kanske frågar.
När det gäller stress och utmaningar och sånt där så är det ju så inne i helvete mycket folk som har detta, att det lär finnas för alla, men ju fler det är på samma kakor desto svårare är det att stå ut.
Och i det här perspektivet så tänker jag att man ganska tidigt behöver nisha sig.
Man behöver titta på vad är det för specifik kundgrupp som jag faktiskt tror att jag har med mig någonting till bordet för va?
Och för så är det ju med all företagsverksamhet.
Håll du med det är det en produkt som marknaden inte vill ha.
Vad ska du göra?
Då spelar det ingen roll hur hårt du köttar liksom.
Och sen handlar det ju också om när du har hittat din målgrupp, vem är det du pratar med?
Män, kvinnor, åldrar, geografisk placering, hur är du relevant?
För det är just det, relevans, relevans, relevans, relevans.
Du måste bli relevant, du måste lösa ett problem eller på något annat sätt nå fram till den här kundgruppen för att de ska uppmärksamma dig.
Och därefter så, okej men hur ska du få dem från att uppmärksamma dig och ta din gratis information till att faktiskt göra ett köp med dig?
Hur ser tröskeln ut?
Hur vill du sova eller föra den här tjänsten?
Är det online eller på plats?
Vad är det du vill göra liksom?
Så jag tänker att steg ett här någonstans det är att titta på dig själv.
Vad är det jag skulle vilja göra?
Vad tycker jag är intressant?
Vad tycker jag är kul att göra?
Finns det något det jag tycker är kul?
Kan jag koka ner den fonden lite till så att jag kanske kan ringa in, är det män eller kvinnor?
Är det en specifik sak där?
Sedan börjar man nysta, det här vill jag jobba med, hur ser man utbildningsprofilet?
Kan ni göra det här?
Nej, det kan jag inte.
Men jag tycker det här är jätteintressant.
Bra, det räcker.
Då hittar vi oss en utbildning.
Och så börjar vi med en.
Så fort vi är klara med den så börjar vi jobba.
Många, många, många patienter i ryggen är fasigt.
Och sen utbildar man sig på vägen.
Jag är inte psykolog, jag är inte läkare.
Jag är ett terapeut, jag har knutna grejer under åren.
Som jag har sett, det här kommer att funka skitbra för mina patienter.
Så går man en utbildning och bara, wow!
Ja, det stämde.
Så jobbar man med det och så har man med sig det gamla.
Sen så visar det sig att den här luckan har jag.
Fan, jag når inte riktigt, just det här är svårt för mig.
Man kanske jobbar med stress och liknande, sen så kommer man på det, men så fort det börjar handla om förhållande, relationer, så blir det svårt för mig.
Jag kanske inte har den vanan hemifrån, kanske inte jobbat så mycket med det.
Nej okej, men läs då.
Börja med att läs och sen gör en googling, hur hittar vi ämnen, relationer, anknytningsmönster och sånt.
Och så bygger man den profilen.
Det är den vägen jag tycker att man ska gå.
Jag tycker att den är bättre.
Det behövs psykologer också, jättemånga, och mycket, mycket mer än vad finns idag.
Men det är också en väldigt lång väg att gå.
Det är ju fem bast på universitetet.
Det tar lång tid.
För att jobba som terapeut behöver du inte det.
Du har ändå ett stort ansvar men det är ingen legitimationskrav på att kalla sig terapeut.
Så det är ett stort ansvar men inte något som en myndighet kontrollerar i dagsläget.
Fantastiskt svar.
Så jag hade nog vågat tidigt titta på marknader, business för att se hur ska det här fungera.
Det är samma intäktsmodeller.
Ska du ta betalt per timme?
Ja men då måste du ha ganska många timmar i veckan.
Vad händer när du inte har det?
Okej, med alla tjänsteföretag, alla konsulter får ha exakt samma problem.
Det finns ingen passiv intäkt.
Okej, börja lösa det problemet tidigt i ditt företagande.
Hur ska jag få in det när jag sover?
Det är liksom fasigt.
Jag hoppas alla personliga tränare och masseurer och liknande förstår att detta är precis lika relevant för dem.
Verkligen, det kan ju vara en online-kurs, det finns jättebra plattformar idag.
Men framförallt att du ska bli relevant inom en nisch, för annars blir du ingenting.
Nej, relevans, relevans, relevans.
Det kan också bli så att man blir relevant för att man har en väldigt stor erfarenhet.
Så det ena utnärslutar inte det andra.
Det är inte det att du måste ha en utbildning med sexbokstäver i förkortningen, utan du kan bli relevant på helt andra sätt.
Bara ju vara igenkännande i sociala medier.
Jag får alltid ont i knänarna, jag gör knädböj.
Okej, knäkillen.
Det är ett bra namn.
Nu ska vi inte hålla det för länge här, Björn.
Det var ett fantastiskt avsnitt.
Om man inte kan få nog av din lätt sensuella röst, hur...
Ja, då kan jag ringa hem också om det är...
Du har ju en podd själv där du har lite kortare avsnitt, och de är rätt nischade varje avsnitt, så att man kan hitta...
Om jag vill lyssna på just ångest, så är det 10 minuter om ångest eller 10 minuter åttämtning.
Vad heter podden?
Den heter Stress och utmattning med Björn Rudman.
Den ligger på alla plattformar som finns.
Spana in, för det är väldigt lätt att söka i, framförallt om man vill...
Det är inte så mycket pladder, utan det är 10 minuter non-stop, snack om just det ämnet och så kan man gå vidare.
På tolv marknad och sånt.
Jag ändrar ju det i somras.
Jag hade 45 minuters avsnitt innan på just den här podden, det här är podden nummer tre i ordningen.
Men när jag gick över på kortare avsnitt, och så två gånger i veckan så bara smalde.
Vi har ungefär strax över 50 000 nedladdningar i dagsläget.
Så korta avsnitt, kort och konstigt, pang, färdigt.
Så kopplar jag artiklar till på hemsidan så man kan läsa lite mer om det du pratade om.
Så kan man lyssna på avsnittet där.
Så björunant.se är det.
The place to be.
Ja, där jobbar jag mycket med artiklar.
Fyller upp det med innehåll och allt möjligt.
Allt från återhämtning till stress till familjegrejer till omjust, till mat, till sådär liksom.
Ibland har jag inte tid att jobba.
Jag förstår.
Ja, vi får säga ett stort enormt tack för att du tog dig tiden att komma hit.
Ja, det var bara kul.
Ja, skitroligt.
Jag har trött med en egen röst här också nu så nu ska jag skita.
Rila lite.
Så jävla gött.
Tack.
In, faxerat, liv.
Alltså det ska gå fort va?
Och sen är du klar.
That's it.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag är 86.